The last value printed by this loop is 2,000. This is a little bit weird,
because the loop's condition says that it only runs as long as n is less than
1,000. Let's hand trace this code to see how this happened. I'll track the
values of n, and what gets output. I start by setting n to two. And then I
check, n is less than 1,000, which is true. Two is less than 1,000. So I set n
to be 10 times 2. And then I print out n. So I print out 20. Now, I'm at the
end of the curly braces. So I go back up to the top of the loop and check the
condition again. N is 20 now, which is still less than 1000. So I'm going to
repeat the steps inside the loop again. I'l set n to 10 times 20. So I get 200.
And then I print out 200. I get to the curly brace, so I go back up to the top
of the loop again. 200 is less than 1,000, so we'll repeat the loop again. I'll
set n to 10 times 200 over 2,000, and then print 2,000. And now I'm at the
bottom of the loop, so I come back up and check the ignition. 2000 is less 1000
is no longer true. So I'm going to skip to the bottom and be done. It looks
like the last thing that was printed was 2000. And we managed to print a larger
value of n than 1000 because the print statement comes after we update the loop
variable. It matters when we update the n inside the body of the loop.